[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome channel awesomes
orbit report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Ruth and I'm Anna Wade and
this is your news for Monday October
23rd well for a while we had a tradition
here on orbit report we did it wasn't an
episode of orbit reports without some
titans casting news and guess what that
tradition is alive again because we got
some new casting news from Titans and it
is one that I am so excited about
waiting I'm so excited so Ryan Potter is
going to be our beast boy and you might
know Ryan Potter best as hero the voice
of hero on big hero 6 but one of the
reasons I am so excited personally for
this casting is a little while ago Ryan
put out his own kind of audition reel
for a Tim Drake Robin for Ben Affleck he
wanted to be the Tim Drake Robin in the
new Batman solo film so he made this
whole reel of him fighting and then at
the end even like sat down and was like
hey Ben
I should be Tim Drake hey Ben like Tim
said Batman needs a Robin and so I'm
just so happy for him that he is
officially a part of the DC Universe he
may not be Robin right that's fine he's
a part of it right I love it I'm so
excited for it like a like a concept
fight standpoint it was a really well
made thing you should definitely go
check it out
and as someone who makes me in phones oh
that's amazing that he's in the DC
Universe
I am super geeking out on his behalf but
also like for like oh come on that's
such a great story it is you want to do
it you got it I'm proud of you buddy
you made your dream your own yeah I mean
he's a really good fighter what he's
shown so he's definitely gonna have the
stunts down he seems like a really good
fit as long as they don't mess
yeah exactly and so beast boy since he's
able to change shapes and stuff like
they could go wrong so easily however
since they got someone with a combat
background my hopes are up again because
it if he can do his own stunts like come
on that's there's some really really
great ground here yeah for sure in other
casting news a Hellboy just announced
three new cast members for its upcoming
film Sophie Okonedo Doctor Who and Hotel
Rwanda she's going to be playing lady
Hatton also Alistair patrie a night
manager amazing and Roebourne come on
yeah he's going to be playing Lord Adam
glaring and then lastly but definitely
not least Irish actor Brian Gleeson of
Assassin's Creed mother plenty of other
things it's going to be playing Merlyn
so that's the most news we've had from
helpful in a little bit yeah ever since
we got those production photos that's
right so which I'm still dying over yeah
in other movie news we finally have a
name for the Han Solo movie it is solo
that's it that's it solo a Star Wars
movie a story sorry solo a Star Wars
story I was kind of mad about this like
it just seems so uncreate 'iv and
obvious and I'm concerned for this
project I'm very concerned for this
project I honestly thought it was a joke
at first because Ron Howard announced it
on Twitter and he had the title car like
Chewie gave him the title card or
whatever and I was like wha seriously
this is this is it I'm a little in shock
about this I guess I was expecting a
little more on the title front not that
you know don't judge a book by it's
cover but also like okay that's it great
like I said a little concerned about
this project I bet you all could come up
with a better name let us know in the
comments below what should this film's
name be definitely shouldn't be so low I
don't know I feel pretty strong
yeah sure okay was that I guess in other
Star Wars news we got a new trailer for
battlefront 2 which is coming out soon
and guys I'm so excited about this and
this trailer just totally added to the
hype if you played the other battlefront
games you know that first of all the
first one didn't really have a story
mode and then they got a story mode and
it was kind of like okay it was fine but
this seems very story mode centric and I
am all on board for it it takes place
but between Return of the Jedi and force
awakens
so we actually started you saw them
starting on Endor as things go to hell
and the Death Star to blows up and
you're playing the daughter of an
imperial Admiral Admiral of versio and
I'm I was so excited to see some
characters that we saw in the trailer -
there was some Luke there are some Leia
there was some man yes
so I I cannot wait to play this it comes
out on November 17th and I'm so excited
the animation looks incredible yes oh my
goodness yeah if we just put the
cutscenes into a movie for sure another
trailer that dropped this week was the
eye Tania trailer starring Margot Robbie
it's a retelling of the Tonya Harding
ice-skating story you know that story
that we keep hearing didn't need another
retelling of this it's captured the
hearts of America I mean man
documentaries have been made other
stories booths of the story Tonya
Harding's also still around so I know
you like it's weird that we keep
bringing it up since no news has come
from it she hasn't changed her side of
the story even in the trailer Margot
kind of well as Tanya's yeah he's like
yeah the truth is a real type of thing
and kind of lead you to believe that
she's gonna make up the story or tell
her side of the story which is what
we've been getting
I don't know I don't see anything new
here although I will say at the end of
the trailer it was giving reviews that
said things like
hilarious so yeah did a dark comedy I
think that would be the best way to do
okay you're gonna do something like this
again you might as well have it from a
new angle in a dark comedy yeah would be
pretty interesting like that's the only
way left to tell it we don't need a
drama by any means but a dark comedy I
could kind of get behind yeah so that
comes out December 8th so we only have a
little bit luck to wait for that another
trailer that came out this week was an
Icelandic horror film called I remember
you it looks super terrifying I got
goosebumps just watching the trailer so
that's usually a really good sign it was
a horror movie if I get creeped out
during just the trailer now this has
English subtitles however we don't have
information on if it's going to be
coming out and limited theaters or if
it's a limited release at all
but we do know the release date is
November 10th so we'll wait to hear more
information about that film but it
sounds super spoopy and in the mood for
spoopy so for you that for me another
trailer that we saw was we got a new
trailer for the Punisher and finally got
a release day for release date for it
you know it's been a little bit of a you
know they cancelled their New York Comic
Con stuff because there was speculation
at first that maybe it was gonna drop on
New York Comic Con but then given you
know they canceled some stuff and in the
original trailer the release date was
blurred out so now we know for certain
it is coming to us on November 17th on
Netflix so it's pretty soon it's it's
almost a month away but it could have
been sooner so it could've yeah I don't
know and this new trailer I was I'm
still a little leery of it but the new
trailers a lot more character centric
which is what I loved about him in the
end daredevil so I hope that that means
that the show is also gonna keep that
same character centric focus with some
action although there was still a whole
bunch of action tossed in there The
Punisher I get it right you're gonna be
involved rightly some cool explosions
that he walks away without looking into
like that happens right it's gonna
happen
more than that for this story otherwise
why tell the story again right and it
seems like we're gonna get a lot more of
his military background involved in this
see how he became a hitman a little bit
more into his vigilante history but
we've kind of already explored his
history so I don't know what other
layers they can add to it so I guess
I'll be interested in seeing what other
layers they can add to it and it doesn't
seem too connected to the other Netflix
series except for we got Karen in there
that's right a little concerned for
Karen though because it showed her in
some she didn't look distressed so I'm a
little concerned for Karen I mean she
looks great I mean yes yeah looking
great another trailer that we've all
been waiting for and the reason why you
click on this episode let's be real is
the Black Panther trailer that came out
this week and it looks amazing I'm we
still have to wait until February to see
the movie but man I have ate up every
little bit of information that they've
given me in these trailers and it still
looks awesome nothing in any trailer has
to be weighed don't give me too much
more information though all right wait
right seriously just given me these
little teases is quite enough but the
design in it looks incredible it looks
super close to the comics and also
taking some liberties of their own with
costuming and even some of the like
technical aspects of the suit look
really cool shredding through clothes
and stuff like that Michael B Jordan
looks incredible his whole like skin
stippling oh my yeah yeah I don't know
under skin graft bang bumpy tattoo Eve
it looks awesome
yeah body mods looks really cool and he
has his own suits in this one that's got
some like gold details on so I don't
know it man every little bit they've
given us in this looks so cool yeah yeah
I really thought that the sound the song
that went along with this trailer did an
excellent job it was really good I don't
want to distract from it at all I didn't
like move along this little tiny short
bit of the story that they were giving
us
tying everything together yeah I don't
know much about Black Panther to be
honest I haven't read many of the comics
so I mean I was intrigued after he
showed up in Civil War but after this
trailer I am a thousand percent on board
so the relationships that kind of are
going on in the newest comic series if
those are also kind of reflected in this
movie or if they're going to shy away
from that a little bit so I its man I'm
so I'm super excited something else that
happened this week is something I was
very very excited about so there was a
mech battle like legit giant robot guys
America versus Japan they've been hyping
this up I mean for years my husband and
I backed the Kickstarter of the American
one it was the American megabots with
their robot Eagle Prime and then from
Japan there was suidobashi corporation
had made their robot coup d'etat and
guys it was a flaming testifier it was
so boring and those of us who were so
excited for it we're beyond disappointed
it was obviously taped ahead of time
there was just a lot of shoving going on
it was shove fest 27 I got 20 17 I guess
where they were just pushing into each
other and I was beyond disappointed I
know it was angering maddening because
it had so much potential
they had pilots and everything Gundams
could be real and then we got a
disappointing he's a pointing gun the 30
minute twitch stream that wasn't even
live on that no seem that we missed
anything this week let us know in the
comments down below or if you have
anything to say about the things that we
talked about this week also let us know
in the comments down below or you can
follow us on social media how there
where can they find you you can find me
on Twitter at Heather roofs Instagram at
a truce or twitch twitch TV slash how
their roofs and as always you can find
me at Facebook Ayanna Wade or everywhere
else as awesome Ayanna so we're gonna
get out of here and see you next week
for Halloween in the meantime stay
spooby friends beam us up
[Music]
you